ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อัดดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนเย้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาเรียน
ภาษาไทยในช่องของเรียนสโมทัยกันอีกครั้ง
หนึ่งครับหน้าโอเคอ้าวันนี้วันนี้เรา
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันหน้าเหมือนเดิมเดิมนะ
เราต้อง
พูดวันที่ก่อนนะครับ 5 วันนี้วันนี้เรา
เรียนภาษาไทยกันวันอะไรครับวันนี้วันนี้
วันจันทร์วันนี้วันจันทร์หรอนี่ครับวัน
นี้วันจันทร์ว้าววันจันทร์วันนี้วัน
จันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันจันทร์ที่ 6 หน้าวันจันทร์ที่ 6 ค่ะเค
แล้วเดือนนี้ล่ะครับเดือนนี้เดือนอะไร
ครับ
เดือนนี้เดือนธันวาคม 5 เดือนธันวาคม
โอเคเดือน
อีกเเล้วฮ่าอ่าปีนี้ปีคศอะไรครับ
ปีคศ
2010  21  21 โอเคน้องเรียมกำลังคิดอยู่
ปีอะไรพีอะไรใช่ไหมฮ่าๆๆเขตแล้วปีพตตปีพต
อะไรครับมีผช
2564  5
วันนี้วันนี้วันจันทร์ใช่ไหมวันนี้วัน
จันทร์แล้วเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์ค่ะ 5 วันนี้วันจันทร์
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์เขา ka เมื่อวานวัน
อาทิตย์วันนี้วันจันทร์แล้วเองพรุ่งนี้
ล่ะครับก็พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารค่ะอ๋ออ๋อวันนี้วัน
จันทร์พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารวัน
อังคาร
โอเควันนี้วันจันทร์เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
โอเคแล้ววันนี้วันนี้ที่เราเรียนภาษาไทย
กันกับวันนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
3:00 นบ่ายที่
05:05 น
3:00 น 5 นาทีใช่ไหมครับ 5 นาทีเป็นบ่าย
นะตอนบ่ายนะตอน 15:00 น 6 มีพระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์โอเคป่ะให้
15:05 อ่อโอเค
ยังหนาวอยู่เลยค่ะยังหนาวหรอโอ๊ยตายพี่
อัดดีก็หนาวนิดหน่อยเมียที่ใส่เสื้อแขน
ยาวแขนยาวเสื้อแขนยาวเยอะตี้หน้าอกหน้า
น้องเรียมหนาวไหมข้าวพันคอหนาวค่ะใส่ผ้า
พันคอหนาว
ก็แล้วเองหน้าหนาวหน้าหนาวเราใส่เสื้อแขน
ยาวเพราะว่าเราหนาวอ่ะแล้วเราใส่อะไรอีก
ครับเวลาที่เราหนาว
เราก็จะใส่เสื้อกันหนาวอ๋ออ๋อเสื้อกัน
หนาวเสื้อกันหนาวมีเสื้อกันหนาวอะไรบ้าง
ครับน่ะเรียกที่มีรูปเสื้อกันหนาวมาด้วย
นะครับค่ะนี่รูปแรกครับมีแฟนเสื้อกันหนาว
[เพลง]
เสื้อกันหนาวแบบนี้คนไทย
เขาเรียกว่าเสื้อโค้ทอ๋ออ๋อเสื้อโค้ท
เสื้อโค้ทอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่านี่เสื้อโขง
a แล้วอันนี้เสื้อโค้ทไหมครับ
เสื้อโค้ทยาวอ๋ออ๋อเป็นเสื้อโค้ทยาว
เสื้อโค้ทยาวจะยาวลงมาแบบนี้ใช่ไหมยาวหรอ
อ๋อค่ะแล้วตัวนี้ตัวนี้
ยาวไหม
เสื้อโค้ทสั้นหาตัวนี้ไม่ยาวตัวนี้เป็น
เสื้อโค้ทสั้นน้อ k  k ตัวนี้ซื้อโค้ดยาว
เสื้อโค้ทสั้นๆอ๋อผู้ชายนี่คนนี้ผู้ชาย
ใส่เสื้อโค้ทสั้นใช่ไหมสั้นสไอเข้าไหนแถว
นี้สั้นสั้นนะฮะ
โอเคออแล้วผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอ่าใส่เสื้อโค้ท
อย่าใช่ไหมครับอ๋อๆเลยค่ะ
เสื้อโค้ทลองวาดรูปได้ไหมคะอ้าได้ครับราะ
ว่าน่าจะวาดรูปอะไรครับ
เรียงจะวาดปุ๊บ
วันนี้วันนี้น้องเรียมว่าได้แล้วเขานัก
เรียนเย้เดี๋ยวว่าได้แล้ว
ดีใจอ่าปาร์ตี้ดีใจที่น้องเล่มวาดได้นะ
ครับอ๋อ
งานน้องๆวาดอะไรนะครับนักเรียนช่วยกันดู
ช่วยครัวตี้สวยเบียร์ตีดูอ่ะอ่ะน้องเรียน
วาดอะไรครับเนี่ยผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อโค้ทผู้
หญิงใส่เสื้อมด
อันนี้คือตัวผู้หญิงนะคะอ๋อใส่เสื้อฟ้าซ
แต่
ขอเป็นเสื้อโค้ทยาวใช่ไหมให้ยาวเข้าเขา
อยู่ตรงนี้ข่าว
ยาวลงมาข้างล่างนี่ก็เสื้อโค้ทยาวหน้า
เหมือนผู้หญิงในรูปนี้นะครับก็ใส่เสื้องด
ยาวเหมือนกันน้อ
แต่ถ้าเป็นเสื้อโค้ทสั้น
เหมือนที่ผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายใส่เสื้อโค้ทสั้นอาหารทำ
ก็จะยาวแค่นี้
ขอ
ก็จะสั้นกว่าสั้นใครค่ะมีเป็นเสื้อโค้ทจะ
ไม่ลงมาข้างล่าง
ขอเวลาเราหนาวเราก็ใส่เสื้อโค้ทขนาวมากก็
ใส่เสื้อโค้ทยาวใช่ไหมก็ได้ค่ะๆแล้วถ้า
หนาวไม่มากหนาวนิดหน่อยใส่เสื้อโค้ทสั้น
ได้ใส่เสื้อโค้ทสั้นได้อ่ะเหมือนผู้ชายคน
นี้ใส่เสื้อโค้ทสั้น
โอเคแต่เตรียมใส่เพราะว่าเรียงคิดว่าสวย 5
ๆดูแล้วแบบก็ไม่ได้หนาวมากใช่ไหมแต่สวย
ไม่ส่วนดูแล้วแบบออกครับใส่ขอเออใส่เสื้อ
โค้ทโอเคอ่ามีเสื้อโค้ทเวลาที่เราหนาวเรา
ใส่เสื้อโค้ทแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับ
มีเสื้อกันหนาว
แบบอื่นๆอีกค่ะอ๋ออื่นยังชอบสีแดงนะพี่
อ่ะครับก็เสื้อกันหนาวสีแดงนะเรียนชอบสี
แดงโอเคอ่า
รอสตี้ L พี่อ่ะชอบสีแดงแต่เพื่อที่ไม่มี
เสื้อสีไหนแห้งเอา
เพศอิสมีสีน้ำเงินใต้มีสีน้ำเงินสีดำสี
เขียวไม่มีสีแดง
ชาย
โอเคอ๋อเรียนชอบสีแดงใช่ไหม ok สีแดงสวย
ได้ไหมครับ
[เพลง]
k5 เดี๋ยวเราไปดูเสื้อกันหนาวตัวต่อไป
เสื้อกันหนาวตัวต่อไปนี่ครับโอ้โหตัวนี้
ตัวนี้เรียกคนไทยเรียกเสื้ออะไรครับ
คนไทยเรียกเสื้อมีฮู๊ดมีฮู๊ดก็คือมีตรง
นี้ใช่ไหมครับเป็นหมวกเป็นหมวกที่ติดอยู่
กับเสื้อนะครับ
50 อยู่กับเสื้อเคเป็นมั่วแต่ติดตรงนี้
ติดกัน
ติดการน่าติดกับเสื้อถึงนี้อ้ามีหมวกมี
หมวกใช่ครับน้อคนไทยก็เรียก Hood  Hood
r&k
rr3 อังกฤษก็เรียก Hood เหมือนกันเป็น
พุทธใช่ครับ 5 พูดใส่เราก็
ประเมินหยิบหาคลุมลุง
โอเค 5 เป็นเสื้อมีฮู๊ดเคครับเฮียตีก็มี
นะเสียนี่ก็มีเสื้อฮู้ดนี่หยิบให้ดู
อย่างรวดเร็วนี้เอาเป็นเสื้อมีฮู๊ดเวลา
ตีใส่ก็จะมีพูดแบบนี้มาตุ่มหน้านี้
ครับคลุมได้เป็นเสื้อมีฮู้ดแขนยาวที่มี
หญ้า
เสื้อฮู้ดจะหูนิ่งมันสีอะไรคะของพี่
อาร์ตี้ต่อวินาทีเสือหูสีคมี
สีเขียวครับแต่ว่าตอนนี้ตอนนี้นักเรียน
ตอนนี้น้องเรียนอาจจะเห็นสีไม่ค่อยเขียว
เท่าไหร่เว้นสีเขียวสีเขียวอ่าสีเขียวออก
สีเขียวเราเรียกว่าสีเขียวอ๋ออะไรอ่ะอ่อน
ๆอ่ะแกครับเขียวอ่อนใช่ครับมีฮูดมีวุฒิ
เหมือนกันอ่ะมีฮู๊ดแบบนี้เช็คกลุ่ม
โอเคอ่านี้เสื้อกันหนาวแบบมีฮู๊ดใช่ไหม
ครับเจ๊มีแบบอื่นอีกนะครับเฮียตี๋ยังมี
เสื้อกันหนาวแบบอื่นอีกให้อ่านักเรียนได้
อยากดูกันว่ามีเสื้อกันหนาวหลายๆแบบเรียง
เรียกว่าอะไรนะครับ 5 ตัวต่อไปครับตัวต่อ
ไป
นี่ดูตัวนี้ครับ
กันหนาวเสื้อกันหนาวเหมือนกันกันหนาวเวลา
นั้นน่ะจะเอามากๆเราใส่เสื้อกันหนาวแบบ
นี้แฮ่เสื้อกันหนาวแบบนี้เรียกเรียดเสื้อ
กันหนาวอะไรครับ
เสื้อกันหนาวขนเป็ดอ๋ออ๋อเสื้อกันหนาวขน
เป็ด 5 มีขนเป็ดมีขนเป็ดอยู่ในเสื้อนี้
ใช่ไหมมีขนเป็ดอยู่ข้างในขอขอบคุณเป็ด
หน่อย
เคขนเป็ดมันคนพูดเนธเป็นยังไงครับขอขอนี่
มีๆกับๆๆอ๋ออ๋อน้องเรียมกำลังวาดรูปขน
เป็ดหรือว่ารูปเป็ดก่อน
เป็ดเป็ดของคนไทยร้องยังไงครับน้องเรียม
เป็ดร้องก้าบๆๆๆ
แต่ถ้าเป็ดของฝรั่งเศษของชาวต่างประเทศจะ
ร้อง
Kwai แหววอย่าให้เขาท้อแขวนแขวน
แต่คน
กับๆๆอ๋อแล้วเราขนมันมาใช่ไหมเอาขนตรงไหน
ครับขนตรงไหนของเป็ดนะเอออ่าเราก็จะเอาขน
ตรงนี้
คนตรงนี้
หน้าตรงปีใช่ไหมตรงๆตัวๆแบตมีขนหาโอเค
ขนเป็ดขนเป็ดขนเป็ดก็จะเป็นแบบนี้อ่ะอ่ะ
ท่านี้ครับที่คนตัดฮิคน 8 อะไรเขาส่วน
เป็นมันไม่ใช่ใบไม้นักเรียนต้องดูให้ดีนะ
คนเป็ด
นับอยู่ข้างในเอาก่อน 8 นี้มาใส่เข้าไปใน
เสื้อนี้อ้าเวลาเราใส่เราก็กันอ้าเวลาเรา
ใส่เราก็จะอุ่นแต่ก็ทำไปหนาวเพราะว่ามีขน
เป็ดอยู่ใช่ไหมครับน้า
โอเคถ้ามีเสื้อขนเป็ดเสื้อขนเป็ดอาบ้าง
ที่บางทีนักเรียนจะได้ยินคนไทยเรียกเหรอ
เป็นเสื้อนวม
เสื้อกันวนๆครับเพราะว่ามันมันหนามากตัว
มันจะหนาเวลาใส่รถตัวจะใหญ่เสื้อหน่วงได้
ครับเออ
คนไทยก็จะเรียกเสื้อกันหนาวอายเขาก็ได้ก็
ได้ตัวกันหนาวขนเป็ด 5 ดารายได้ครับและ
นวมกระดาได้ได้ใช่ครับหน้านี้เป็นเสื้อนม
อาเสื้อกันหนาวขนเป็ดอ่ะเหมือนกันเคหนาว
ขนเป็ดสีแดงอ๋อเหรอหรอว่าเอาเรียนต่อปสี
แดงเสื้อกันหนาวขนเป็ดสีแดงสวยๆ
เนื้อหามีเสื้อกันหนาวขนเป็ดแล้วมีเพื่อ
กันหนาวแบบไหนอีกครับ
นี่แบบนี้ครับหน้าแบบนี้
อ่าน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับอ่า
อธิบายให้นักเรียนให้นักเรียนฟังหน่อย
เรียมเห็นผู้หญิงหอผู้หญิงน่ะคนนี้เป็น
ผู้หญิงโอเคครับ
ผู้หญิงกอดอกหนอกอดปกใช่ไหมนี่ก่อนออกใช้
มือกอดกอดกกกอดน้องกอดปลอกผู้หญิงคนนี้
ยืนกอดอกอยู่อ่ะโอเคครับใส่ผ้าพันคอ
ผ้าพันคอลลี่คอมีผ้าผ้าพันคอใช่ไหมอ๋ออ่า
ผู้หญิงคนที่ใส่ผ้าพันคอเหมือนน้องเรียน
พี่น้องเรียมก็ใส่ใส่ผ้าพันคอใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะผ้าบางใส่ผ้าพันคอพันพันเท่าที่คอ
พาณิชย์พันธุ์
อันของขอเป็นผ้าพันคอของเออโอเค
อ่า
ของอนิผ้าพันคอแล้วมีมีอะไรอีกครับตรงนี้
กลัวตีเห็นเปียที่เห็นตรงนี้สีดำสีดำเป็น
เสื้อเสื้ออะไรครับ
เป็นเสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนังอ๋ออ๋อเสื้อแจ็ค
เก็ตหนัง
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นเสื้อหนังใช่ไหมเสื้อแจ็คเก็ต
หนังขอไปค่ะเวลาหนาวเราใส่เสื้อแจ็คเก็ต
หนังได้เหมือนกันจะน่ะอ๋อ
น้องเวียร์มีเสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนังไหมครับ
ไม่มีค่ะขอไม่จะมี R  R ไม่มีใช่ไหมครับ
ไม่หนาวสิพี่อาร์ตี้หนาวหนาวแบบไม่มีหนาว
มีแบบอื่นนี่ก็ไม่มีเพี้ยนดีไม่มี
เสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนัง
ทรายที่มีเป็นเสื้อกันหนาวแบบนี้แบบที่มี
ฮู๊ดแล้วก็เป็นเสื้อแขนยาวแบบนี้
ใช่เพราะว่าเพราะว่าที่ประเทศไทยไม่หนาว
มากหนาวนิดหน่อยหนาวไม่มากสร้างใช่ค่ะ
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนตอนเรียมเด็กๆเตรียม
เด็กๆหนาวมากๆอ๋อประเทศไทยหนาวมาก
หนาวมากหนาวเออโอเคแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ไม่
หนาวใช่ไหมไม่หนาวที่หนาวหนาวนิดหน่อย
ใช่ปีก่อนหน้าหนาวแค่
2 วันหนาวสองอัน
หนาวนิดเดียว 2 วันที่แล้วใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยว
จะปีนี้ปีนี้หนาวนาน
นานกว่าจะไม่เอาใช่ค่ะนี้ปี
2021 หนาว
หนาวนานมากนานหนาวกี่วันเขาหนาวที่วัน
เต็มคิดว่า
มากกว่าเหรอ
มากกว่า 1  1 สัปดาห์แล้วอ๋ออ๋อมากกว่า
หนึ่งสัปดาห์
มากกว่า
มากกว่าหนึ่งสัปดาห์ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอ๋อโอเค
โอเค
หน้าท่าโอเคกลับอามาที่เสื้อกันหนาวนี้
เรียกเรียกเสื้อกันหนาวอะไรนะครับ
เรียกเสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนังเสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนัง
โอเคมีเสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนังแล้วมีเสื้ออะไร
อีกครับนี่ครับ
แบบนี้เรียกกันหนาวขอเป็นเสื้อกันหนาว
เหมือนกันอ่ะครับขนแกะขนแกะ
นี้ใช่ไหมครับอันนี้เป็นขนแกะหนอคำมาจาก
ขนแกะแกะขนแกะสีขาว
ค้ารู้จักแกะไหมคะ 5 รู้จักแกะไหมให้ให้
น้องเรียมวาดแกะให้ดูหน่อยแกะคืออะไรครับ
แก่เออ
แก้แก่คนไทยกับแกะ
แก่ชาวต่างชาติขอเพียงตีคิดว่าน่าจะร้อง
เหมือนกันนะแกะเนี่ยแกะร้องยังไงคะพี่
แอปปี้
แก่ก็ล็อคแม่มีอ้าใช่ไหมครับแก่อ่อนี่มา
แล้วแกะอ่า
แกะของน้องเรียมตัวสีดำเลย
เป็นแกะดำเนื้ออ่ะแกะดำโอเค
[เพลง]
นะเฮียตี้ปาสแกะ
แก่เครียดหรือวัดแกะสีขาวใช่
สีขาว
ก็อ้ามีปากเกย์ใว้
[เพลง]
มีตาด้วยโอเคไว้แหกไอ้เนี่ยไม่ตีรู้สึก
ว่าเป็นเหมือนกัน
นะอ้ามีอามาด้วย
อาการแก้มีสี่ขานะโอเคอ่าได้อยู่สิขาแกะ
มีหางไหม
มีหางเหมือนหมาพุดเดิ้ลเลยเนี่ยได้
โอเคประมาณนี้ครับอ้าเป็นแก่เอออ๋ออ๋อเรา
เอาขนแกะขนแกะมาทำเสื้อใช่ไหมเอาขนแกะมา
ทำเสื้อเรียกใช้เสื้อเสื้อเสื้อขนแกะล้อ
นี่เสื้อขนแกะแน่
โอเคอ้ามีเสื้อคนแกะใส่ตอนที่หนาวใช่มั้ย
เป็นอันหนาวใส่เสื้อคนแก่
โอเคอ้ามีเสื้อขนแกะแล้วมีเสื้ออะไรอีก
ครับ
เดี๋ยวเพียงพี่ดูก่อนเสื้อกันหนาวอะไร
อยู่บ้างอะเดี๋ยวตี้เลือกเสื้อกันหนาว 5
อันนี้ครับวันนี้โอ๋โอ๋ตัวนี้เห็นเห็นแบบ
นี้อ่ะอย่าปล่อยเห็นบ่อยๆๆแบบนี้นิเรียก
เสื้อกันหนาวเรียกว่าอะไรครับ
เรียกว่าเสื้อไหมพรมขอเสื้อไหมพรมเสื้อ
ใหม่ Home เที่ยวไหมพรมคืออะไรครับขวดตี้
วอตี้งงเสื้อไหมพรมนะไหมพรมที่
เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
ไหนครับไหนครับไหมพรมเริ่มนักเรียนนัก
เรียนช่วยช่วยพี่ eighteen ดูหน่อยไหมพรม
คืออะไร
ที่เอามาผักๆๆเณรม้วนม้วนแบบนี้ใช่ไหมใช่
อมไฟพรมอ๋อเอามาเอาไหมพรมอยู่หอ
ไหมพรมโอเคโอเคพี่นึกออกแล้วนึกออกแล้ว
โอเคเป็นไหมพรม
แล้วก็เอาไหมพรมมาทำเป็นเสื้อใช่ไหมใช่
อ่ะเราวัยเรียกเสื้อไหมพรมใช่ไหมครับอ้าง
ว่าเป็นไหมพรมแบบนี้มันเหมือนไหมเนี่ย
มันไม่เหมือนนะเนี่ย
ดูยุ่งๆเนี่ยแล้วก็มีเส้นดอกมาอ๋อโอเค
แล้วเราก็เอามาถักแบบนี้ใช่ไหมอ่ะมีอะไร
ค่ะๆแล้วก็ทำออกมาเป็นไหมพรม
อ้าถ้าเขามาเป็นเสื้อนะอ้าโอเคเป็นเสื้อ
ไหมพรมเย้
เสื้อไหมพรมอุ่นนะเวลาใส่เสื้อไหมพรมแล้ว
ไม่หนาวใช่ไหม
เงินอุ่นอุ่นเห้ยเดี๋ยวนะเคลียร์ติ๊กมี
เสื้อใหม่พร้อมนะอ๋อ
เนื้อ
หาข่าวที่แล้วพี่อ่ะตีก็ใส่เสื้อไหมพรม
นี่เสื้อใหม่พร้อม
เป็นเสื้อไหมพรมเป็นแบบนี้เป็นไหมพรม
มีค่ะเฮนี้เป็นไหมพรมถักเออ
มีสติ๊กเกอร์ใหม่คงครับ
สีอะไรนะคะเสื้อไหมพรมของพี่อาร์ตี้สีสี
อะไรครับนักเรียน
เตรียมคิดว่าสีฟ้าอ่ะใช่ครับเป็นเสื้อไหม
พรมสีฟ้าครับ
[เพลง]
แต่ที่เห็นในรูปในรูปนี้มีเสื้อไหมพรมสี
อะไรครับมีสีน้ำตาล
มีสีน้ำตาลโอเค
แล้วตอนนี้เราครับตัวนี้ 4 อะไรไก่ตรมสี
ขาวเสื้ออยู่ในพรมสีขาวชายวะว้าวหาห๊ะ
เปียตีเห็นอ่านทั้งสองคนทั้งสองคนนี้ใส่
ใส่อะไรครับนี่ข้างบนไปหมวกอ้าเป็นบวกนี่
ใส่หมวกด้วยนะครับ
ก็แต่เวลาที่หนาวแว่นหนาวเราใส่หมวกใส่
หมวกอ่ามีหมูแบบนี้พี่เคยเห็นนี่หมวกแบบ
นี้เวลาที่เราหนาวนี่เป็นหมวกแบบนี้ครับ
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นหมวก
Sharp พวกไหมพรมใช่ไหมคะค่ะใช่ครับเป็น
หมวกไหมพรมเหมือนกันนะเพราะว่ากลับเป็น
ไหมพรม 5
เป็นหมวกไหมพรม
5 มีหมวกไหมพรมส
มีแต่เป็นหมวกนะครับหน้าแล้วก็มีอ้อมีอัน
นี้เป็นผ้าพันคอคอเหมือนกันเหมือนกับพี่
น้องเรียมน้องเรียมก็ใส่ผ้าพันคอ
เออ
โอเคนะครับวันนี้เราก็ได้เรียนรู้เกี่ยว
กับเลือกกันหนาวแล้วก็มีหมวกไหมพรมมีผ้า
พันคอไหมครับนั้นมีอะไรบ้างเดี๋ยวเบียร์
ตีเปิดให้ดูอาให้น้องเรียมอาอา
อ้าเรียกชื่ออีกครั้งหนึ่งทีรัฐภาพอันนี้
เป็นครับเสื้อโค้ท 5 เสื้อโค้ทเสื้อโค้ท
สั้นใช่มั้ยเสื้อโค้ทสั้น 5 แล้วนี้เป็น
เสื้อโค้ทแล้วโค้ชยาวโอเคอ่าแล้วอันนี้
เสื้อมีฮู๊ดมีฮู๊ดใช่ไหมโอเคเป็นเสื้อ
ฮู้ดหาต่อไปอ่านี่ครับอ่าเอาเสื้อกันหนาว
หาเสื้อกันหนาวเสื้อนมหรือว่าเสื้อขนเป็ด
ใช่ไหมเสื้อกันหนาวใช่เห็ดกันหนาวขนเป็ด
แล้วก็อันนี้เป็นเสื้ออะไรครับ
เสื้อแจ็คเก็ตหนังอาร์แจ๊กเก็ตหนังนี้
เสื้อกันหนาวขนแกะเสื้อกันหนาวขนแกะโอ๊ะ
ขึ้นฮิไม่มีครับอันนี้
ไม่เชื่อ
ไปไกลแล้วครับไปไกลแล้วคนแกะแล้วใช่ไหม
กลับไวเอาทิ้ง
ก็เป็นอันนี้ครับมีเป็นเสื้อกันหนาวมั้ย
พร้อม
กันพร้อมแล้วก็มีหมวกไหมพรมใช่ไหมหน้า
แล้วก็ผ้าพันคอผ้าพันคอฮ่าฮ่าโอเคโอเคอ้า
วันนี้
ทั้งหมดเวลาแล้วครับหมดเวลาเรื่องเสื้อ
กันหนาวแล้วนะครับๆเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราว
หน้ากลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับยาตี้กับน้อง
เหลี่ยมกันใหม่นะครับอะไรค่ะคอมเพรนโซโล
ไทยในครับให้ค่ะแล้วเจอเจอกันใหม่ในเขต
อ้าค่ะขาวหน้ากับวันนี้สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีครับน้องเรียนอ่ะสวัสดีนัก
เรียนนี้ค่ะพี่สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ